okay if you were interested in
respectful political discussion on the
Internet which is a rare thing consider
the david pakman show subreddit at david
pakman.com slash our EDD IT we've got
moderators the more than 16,000 of our
viewers and listeners are regularly
participating there and there were some
interesting posts this morning that I
saw and wanted to address one is how
many of y'all think Trump wins
re-election polls indicate top Dems
beating him but those polls don't
indicate turnout ratios I don't care if
a bunch of loony boomers think Biden is
more favorable we need younger people to
turn out in droves yeah you know
yesterday during the impeachment live
stream I said I there are a number of
scenarios in which Trump doesn't get
reelected for example Biden is the
nominee and Biden wins or Bernie is the
nominee and Bernie wins or Warren is the
nut-like I think conceivably all of
those folks could defeat Donald Trump or
Trump is convicted in the Senate
although it's very unlikely on
impeachment I still believe that from a
statistical standpoint the one most
likely scenario the one most likely
scenario is Trump reelection now that
doesn't mean that that is a majority
probability it might be it's a 40
percent chance Trump gets reelected and
it's a five percent chance he gets
convicted in the Senate and it's a 17%
chance Biden's the nominee and defeats
him and a 17 percent series here I'm
saying I'm not saying more than 50% but
I think still the most likely individual
outcome is Trump gets himself reelected
now some people have been writing to me
saying David what's the advantage of
saying that like what are we gained by
you saying you think Trump's going to be
reelected you should be doing this you
should be doing that if you want shows
that do that type of stuff where they
say well here's what I think but that
would be perceived this way or that way
so I'm gonna say this totally different
thing this show has always just been I
tell you what I think and I don't
calculate whether I should tell you what
I think on the basis of how it might
affect ABCD now some people might say
David that's erratic you might be doing
damage to the movement I reject the idea
that merely saying hey guys this is an
uphill battle
I still think given how difficult it is
to knock off an income
president and how unlikely it is Trump's
convicted in the Senate and how it is
still likely that with a small popular
vote loss Donald Trump could still win
the electoral college
that's just my analysis and I will
always give you my analysis now we could
disagree about what Democrats should be
doing on that basis and maybe we do but
that's the way I see it it's an
unfortunate reality also from the David
Pakman show subreddit a poll that shows
generation as Z is even more anti Trump
than Millennials this was very
interesting to see because you've seen a
really big effort from the what I guess
we would call the think tank right or
the on campus right or something like
that
to really start targeting younger voters
and they've been claiming victory
they've been saying you know Millennials
are very left but the next generation
coming up is going to be much more
conservative now let me remind myself of
Gen Z years the that is people born
between 96 and 2010 okay right so even
those 2010 will now be voting in this
upcoming election
it turns out that they seem to be
failing despite all the money that
groups are pouring in to attracting
young people over to their movement on
campuses and in other ways gen Z
according to recent polling is even more
anti Trump then Millennials and we will
see how that is reflected in the 2020
election results but everybody's got to
get registered and everybody's got to go
vote and that's where our focus should
be join the discussion on our subreddit
at david pakman.com slash re d di t